laser cooling means shining light on
stuff and making it cold now that in
itself sounds like it's completely
backwards because after all you
typically think if you shine light on
something it's going to get warm so how
is it even possible to shine light on
something and make it cold to cool the
air down means to make those molecules
atoms in the air move more slowly that's
the difference between hot and cold so
how do you make something cold with a
laser well lasers all white pushes on
stuff there's a thing called radiation
pressure white pushes on things what
we've figured out to do over the years
is how to push on ABS in such a way as
to make them slow down
the thing that was perhaps the the
crowning achievement of the early days
of laser cooling was the discovery that
we made in our laboratory that it was
possible to get these atoms colder than
everyone had thought was the limit to
how cold you could get something the
prediction said that we could get down
to temperatures of 240 millionths of a
degree in other words one quarter of one
thousandth of a degree above absolute
zero pretty cold right well in fact we
got a whole lot colder than that and
that was the big breakthrough discovery
that made a whole lot of other things
possible
well all clocks have tickers all of
these tickers have imperfections every
quartz crystal is made a little bit
differently the length of the pendulum
can change a little bit and that changes
how fast it will swing back and forth so
all of these clocks have imperfections
and so one has throughout history been
trying to make these clocks better by
making the tickers be more reliable that
is always have the same ticking
frequency well it turns out that atoms
are the best choice for making tickers
that always take it the same frequency
even atoms have their imperfections
temperature means that the atoms are
moving with a certain velocity having a
certain kinetic energy the hotter the
gas is the faster the atoms are moving
it's not so easy to measure the ticking
frequency of something that's whizzing
around at the speed of sound and that's
the problem that everybody was facing
with atomic clocks was that the atoms
were moving at approximately the speed
of sound and it wasn't so easy to
measure the ticking frequency so we said
let's cool them down using lasers so
they're going more slowly and that will
make it easier to measure the ticking
frequency and you can make better clocks
when I started doing laser cooling the
very best clocks were accurate to a part
in 10 to the 13 so that's one part / one
with 1300 that's the fractional error in
how good that clock wah sounds
incredible right but today those clocks
are a couple in 10 to the 16 almost
three orders of magnitude better and
that has been made possible because of
laser cooling
I suppose that young children are
curious about everything and very early
my curiosity tended toward curiosity
about science my parents got me a
microscope when I was very young maybe
six years old and I remember looking at
all kinds of things around the house
with this microscope I remember
collecting various household chemicals
and fluids to mix together which was my
homemade chemistry set and in addition I
was doing all the other things that kids
do climb trees and scurry up and down
cliffs and clicked huckleberries in the
woods but there was always a lot of
physical activity and a lot of that
physical activity for me involved doing
things that that related to science
looking at stuff being keria curious
about the natural world
you